Amanda ballet illness from CBS sports
and didn't do well at the Masters when
we had our pics you finished last by the
way man okay are you ready you get the
first pick in the PGA Championship draft
now what we're doing we're not taking
prize money this time around it's total
strokes under par so whatever their
scores are okay okay I don't know if
that factors into your selection process
here but you get the number one pick in
the draft
all right my number one pick well I'm
gonna go Burke's koepcke no surprise
there okay who is second on the list
that would be Todd frit Todd I am going
to grab back-to-back champion Tiger
Woods hey I'm up next I'm gonna take
Dustin Johnson all right am i next
yes I am going to go with and had one in
a long time Rory McIlroy jr. the third
okay Paul you're up his good friends
call him Rick Ricky Fowler Oh Rick
Fowler off the board okay okay McLovin
back to back jack I'll go Tony fee now
and my first pick this is tough you're
I'll go with Justin Rose with my second
fusion Rose all right Oh ball you're
next dan I'll bring it back with Dustin
Johnson I took it oh you do oh I'm sorry
Wow that need to be verbally spanked
Paulie drinks yeah
Thomas flea would yes
fairway Jesus is off the board dan I had
a dream last night that this next player
I'm taking I was only gonna take him I
didn't need to take anybody else because
he was going to win but now that the you
know the way we're scoring this changes
Zander Charlie Sanders awfully is off
the board I'm gonna take up Francesca
I'm Ellen I'm Francesco Molinari I love
that with linguine is up to Todd now I
am gonna go with mr. John Rahm okay now
it's Amanda Amanda you go back to back
Oh miss okay we're gonna go Marc
Leishman one of these days he wins one
of these days it's coming I am convinced
you know what I'm gonna go with Aaron
why Aaron whines did he go to Oregon he
did yeah we won the n-c-double-a
championship I believe in individual and
yeah yeah who's next
tio double D toddler I am looking at mr.
he didn't come through for me at the
Masters but I'm gonna stick to Jordan
speith he's gonna bounce back they'll
jordo is gone next
you know what speaking of fellas who are
do I'm like a Sergio Garcia surge just
sending us an autograph shirt now
Sara who's next Olly do you owe me
Bryson to Shambo welcome to the team
thank you Thank You Amanda yeah that'd
be Pauline polyester Molinari still on
the board
holy what are you listening to the show
that really knows it you should forfeit
this is like the what wasn't that the
Vikings who didn't get their pick in I'm
gonna go Phil Bert Nicholson Phil
Mickelson all righty
okay who's next that'd be me back to
back to back
I'm gonna go hideki Matsuyama all right
there's a bunch of golfers I want here
but I'm gonna go with Patrick Hadley
Patrick aunt Leigh you have no idea who
Patrick kentley is I am it was at a
positive grunt or o-negative he is he I
do think he's gonna win a major at some
point I don't know if this is a week but
he put him C played well the master so
you never know who's next
polyester Justin Rose I scratched off a
bunch a room you should lose a pic Jason
Day watch Jason Day wins yeah I almost
took God Justin Thomas and I found out
he was a scratch Mario didn't tell me
Dan Europe I'm gonna go with Webb
Simpson
yeah I'm gonna take
[Music]
they're not saying boo they're saying
Bubba Watson oh okay next does that mean
yes Todd I am going to go with mr.
Patrick Reed okay did anybody take tiger
yet seaboard yeah who's next
Amanda the man misses it I'm gonna go
with henrik stenson for my final pick
Henrik von Stenson is off the board yes
nobody took Matt Kuchar Paul Casey Adam
Scott the dreamy Adam Scott Gary
woodland Ian Poulter among the favorite
Tigers game compared with this course
Amanda means what that is the ultimate
question isn't it in 2002 when he won
here and it was a US Open he was just
physically better than everyone else so
even when he had to hit it out of the
rough he wasn't penalized the same way
that the players usually are so I think
that's gonna be the big question this
week is one man he I think that the most
important thing this week right is
hitting fairways but if you miss
fairways are you able are you strong
enough are you tough enough to be able
to bounce back without losing a shot you
know from what we saw at the Masters I
think it's hard to it's hard to bet
against tiger woods right now isn't it
especially on the courses that he's
familiar with and has won a major on but
I think honestly the key for him is
going to be maybe dialing it back off
the tee and hitting more fairways that
could be way more important than maybe
bombing it you know 315 off the tee you
played this course haven't you I have
yeah I went the Hofstra so Bethpage
Black is basically in my in my back yard
and I honestly don't remember a ton of
it I probably blocked it out it was
terrible
terribly hardest experience and you know
this is one of those golf course is
similar to Kiawah Island where you're
very thankful you're not playing it you
just get to walk around and watch other
people play it because it is
it's like getting beat up out there it's
a very hard course hey have fun this
week Amanda always great to talk to you
and hopefully we'll get you in the man
cave here on the simulator one of these
days thank you that's Amanda ballet
owners from CBS Sports she'll be doing
the post match interviews for CBS for
more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV streamed
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show at
[Music]